after building an api with apigee and
sharing it with developers there's still
work to be done to make sure that
everyone has a successful experience
as an api producer you may want to know
critical information like how is my api
traffic running over time when is api
response time fastest or slowest and who
are my top developers
the answers to these questions can help
you improve your apis troubleshoot
problems and make better decisions for
your business
this is where apogee analytics comes
into play
apogee analytics collects and calculates
a wealth of information that flows
through api proxies you can visualize
this data in the apogee ui with
pre-defined analytics dashboards as well
as custom reports
apigee analytics can help improve the
api experience for everyone
this data can help provide insight to
the api team about how the api program
is doing overall how individual apis are
doing and how to improve and debug apis
analytics information can also be shared
with app developers who will want to
know how to improve their apps to
increase revenue
the operations team can learn more about
traffic patterns and when to add
back-end resources or make other
adjustments
and the business owner can see whether
or not their initial api investment is
paying off
in other episodes we learned how to
build an api proxy secure apis with api
keys and set up a developer portal
in this episode we'll take a tour of
apogee analytics and learn how can help
you troubleshoot customer issues
[Music]
first visit
apogee.google.com to open the apigee ui
as you can see we've already created
some api proxies and generated some
traffic against them in the left
navigation bar click analyze and then
api metrics
this shows you apogee's pre-built
analytics dashboards for api proxy
performance cache performance error code
analysis latency analysis and target
performance api proxy performance gives
you information about the performance of
your proxy over a period of time
you can see how much overall traffic
you've had including whether it resulted
in success or failure
there's also average response time in
milliseconds
you can also view analytics for a
specific proxy
next up there's cash performance where
you can see the cash hit rate the number
of cash hits and cash response times
you can also take a look at error code
analysis where you can learn about how
many errors occurred and what types of
errors they were
here we have 60 errors that were 404
meaning not found there were also 30
errors that were 401 meaning
unauthorized
these likely happen because the caller
did not provide a valid api key
now let's take a look at latency
analysis
first select a time range of the last
hour
we'll select an api proxy to look at
here we can see some statistics about
response time
at three o'clock in the afternoon the
99th percentile was 97 milliseconds
meaning that 99 of api calls were faster
than 97 milliseconds
we could also see that 95 of api calls
were faster than 14 milliseconds
and of course the median response time
was just two milliseconds
you can analyze response time by the
target as well as request and response
processing latency
there's also a target performance
dashboard to see how fast the backend
system is responding to your requests
this can help you understand when you
might want to use caching
beyond api metrics you can also learn
more about the developers that are using
your apis
under developers you can click developer
engagement
here you can see the total number of
developers the number of developers with
apps and the number of active developers
you can also browse details about
individual applications that developers
have registered using the developer
portal here we have two apps one for
stackdriver monitoring and another for
ping status
for each of these apps we can see the
email of the developer as well as
traffic and error statistics
there's also a traffic composition
section where you can take a look at
your top 10 api proxies by amount of
traffic
in this case the vast majority of api
proxy traffic is for ping status v1
you can also take a look at your top 10
developers by amount of traffic top 10
products by amount of traffic and top 10
apps by amount of traffic
there's also an end users section where
you can see the types of user agents
that are accessing an api proxy
in this case we have some curl calls as
well as some library calls via postman
finally there's a geo map that allows us
to see traffic broken down by country
here we can see that most of our traffic
is coming from the united states but we
also have some traffic from singapore
belgium and brazil
in addition to the pre-built analytics
dashboards you can also create custom
reports
here we have a custom report where we
can see traffic broken down by
application
if you select an application you can
also see the breakdown of traffic by api
call
you can also expand the time frame
beyond the current day
if you want to expand beyond the listed
maximum of 14 days you can submit a job
to handle report generation
asynchronously in the background
you can come back later to see the
results of this custom report
as you can see apogee analytics comes
packed with helpful data visualizations
one key use case for these
visualizations is troubleshooting
data visualization is a powerful way to
unlock compare contrast and assess the
underlying data the apigee collects
about your apis
perhaps you've recently received some
feedback from a customer that one of
your apis is being slow
apogee analytics can help you figure out
exactly what's going on
you can check to see if the slowness is
being seen by just one app or multiple
apps
if it's just being seen by one app there
may be a problem with that app
you can also look to see if the slowness
is concentrated in a certain geolocation
which may suggest a network problem
if neither of these is the case then you
might have a problem with apogee and may
want to look at policy configuration
it may also be helpful to compare the
average response time of different apis
to see if one of them is significantly
underperforming the others
and finally you could generate a custom
report to visualize maximum latency time
by app and resource
thanks for joining us to learn more
about apogee analytics a powerful tool
to help you visualize api data to gain
insights that can help drive business
success
and friends if you found this episode
helpful please click the like button and
subscribe to the channel cheers
you